i got to bring it up again for the 800th
time my friends you've seen it in almost
every segment i've done over the past
few months democrats in the civics poll
believe the economy is good
republicans and independents think the
economy is bad 70 percent of independent
voters believe the economy is to some
degree bad either fairly or extremely
88 of republicans say either fairly bad
or very bad 54 of democrats say the
economy is very good we got the story
from breitbart
consumer sentiment crashes as confidence
in biden economic policy uh i'm sorry
collapses
breitbart says the university of
michigan's preliminary october read of
consumer sentiment fell to 71.4 from
72.8 in september richard curtin the
survey's chief economist explained the
downturn consumer sentiment has remained
for the past three months at the lowe's
first recorded response to the shutdown
of the economy the delta variant supply
shortages reduced labor force
participation rates will continue to dim
the pace of consumer spending into 2022.
there's another less tangible factor
that has contributed to the slum in
optimism confidence in government
economic policies has significantly
declined during the past six months so
there you go my friends there are people
who are living in a cult
they believe for some reason i just i
literally don't understand how they how
they think that things are are going
well
we are being told by gensake
that well it's good that prices are
going up because it means that things
are being sold we saw that article that
was like inflation is actually a good
thing it means you'll make more money no
no no no it means you can't buy stuff it
means you're saving his savings are
being gutted
this reminds me of bernie saying that
bread lines are a good thing that means
there's a bunch of bread like no you're
wrong you're wrong about that i'm
waiting in line to eat it's a good thing
yeah yeah
uh i i we're in this weird limbo right
now where everything is we're still
getting out of uh you know the covid
economy
uh i i'm selling a house right now and
the market is still good but that i mean
you can see can i buy it yeah
[Laughter]
it's in california yeah yeah
but you can keep that sorry well here's
a question though is is
so right now in rural areas rural
property is absolutely bunkers yeah like
property that used to be a couple
hundred grand is now going for a triple
but what about in san francisco is it
going down it hasn't going down yet it
hasn't skyrocketed up but uh san
francisco is it's not the best test
because they don't have a lot of uh
inventory so when a house goes on it's
usually gone and it's bought up by a
company usually who in their right mind
would move to san francisco right now
don't know i don't know we just had a
poll come out recently saying half the
people half of the residents want to
leave
you guys have poop all over your streets
and that's what's the deal that's not
even an over exaggeration it started
drifting out into the outer streets it
used to be just in the tenderloin or on
sixth it's like rolling down the street
it's rolling down california street
going down 101 which they just blocked
off because you can't drive on 101
anymore you can just ride a bike on it
or poop you can poop on it too if you
like nice uh yeah it's terrible it's
terrible i've seen things in california
i never thought i'd see yeah i was in la
and i'm
i was going to a shopping center and
then right in the middle of the street
this large homeless woman just walked
right in spread her legs and squatted
and just went to town
and i was like
what is happening right now this is
crazy welcome to the city i remember
doing a walk and talk that was unedited
and i was just walking down
san francisco down where i think city
hall is at it or the state capitol city
hall city where city hall is it looks
like a state council and i saw a lot of
people taking the vaccine uh
on the streets south administration
ministered
and i saw a lot of different stuff but
as i was filming as i was walking there
was a lady screaming on the top of her
lungs and i see police officers hear
that and literally run the other way and
i'm like this is what's happening one of
america's biggest city with some of the
highest rents how in the world do you
live there
not for long i'm leaving i'm getting the
hell out i was it was enough are you are
you able to tell us what options you're
looking at um like texas uh any place in
the country away from the city yes i
don't want to live in a city at all
anymore i'm done
my house got you know i grew up in san
diego like never had my car broken into
lived in san francisco for 18 years had
my car broken into twice a year wow
twice a year and my wife had hers broken
into it's all the time there's always uh
have you considered chicago
no
surprisingly enough no nice city new
york city is also very charming with uh
you know a lot of people trying to uh
stab you big rats big huge rats that was
they didn't they didn't oversell that
one i couldn't believe it when i saw
that but no no cities i'm done with
cities yeah
sorry go ahead no no i i just the the
crime i don't know how they cut they can
say the economy is good when we have uh
how many
we have there's a help wanted sign in
california everywhere everywhere i go
every shopping center has at least five
if it's not empty it's a cult yeah if if
it's not an empty building it's a help
wanted sign yeah you go to the
supermarket out here and there's there's
a sticker every on like every other uh
like refrigerator door and on every
aisle multiple times saying 500 sign-on
bonus
and these people are just like i think
the economy is good yeah i try to go to
a restaurant earlier today uh the first
two all closed when that said it was
open the waffle house was closed yeah
that that's what you know
yeah i've seen a lot of things i've seen
people die before my eyes but when i saw
a waffle house closed my heart felt like
it was being just strained and i was
like
true story uh there is a starbucks near
my house that ran out of coffee because
it's a supply line chain wow ran out of
coffee had the clothes
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna i wanna
just gloat when i was saying like hey
you should get emergency food a year ago
because you never know like sometimes it
rains there could be a flood the road
might get closed and you got it you
could have some food and water in the
closet you can pop up when you need it
and all these lefties were like tim's so
dumb he's telling people to boil
emergency food and now we're going on
like year two of supply chain collapse
yeah yeah
well you know go to your store there's
food i'm not saying people are starving
right now but i'll tell you this the
prices for emergency food is like
doubled or tripled some shops don't sell
them anymore so if you got it you're
good if you don't
yeah and bitcoins through the roof um
what's it called i already made a list
here bitcoins up stocks bonds copper all
up confidence crashes near decades low
as the washington post is literally
writing articles that are entitled
america needs higher longer-lasting
inflation i mean
how more criminal could you get when you
look at inflation it predominantly makes
people poor already the cost of living
astronomically high the cost of food
higher than it ever has been for the
average american in everything for the
basic cost of living is going up wages
staying the same what did they call it
was it reuters they called it a great
reboot yeah a great yeah a great reboot
yeah no real yeah i think reuters did
right right yeah i think so the reboot
it's like guys we know what the great
reset is we need a word
yo man bitcoin is what like 62k
yeah imagine how many how many people i
remember uh because we talked about it
i'll just say this right away like why
bitcoin works it's decentralized
it is better than all the other cryptos
in my opinion and when you've got a
failing us economy and failing u.s
policy bitcoin is global and
decentralized so it's much much more
difficult to actually manipulate now a
lot of people say oh but elon musk
tweets and he manipulates it nah you
don't you don't get it we know what the
real value of that coin is and basically
right now that means you're buying at a
discount but i remember when it hit
and a bunch of people were like
oh you know it's a bubble and then it
fell down to 30 and they started saying
like see that proves it and i'm sitting
back like okay sell your bitcoin then
and they did and poor people were
selling now it's back up over 60. it's
it's highest point isn't it um i don't i
don't know exactly i have to double
check that to make sure i'm accurate
61
351 dollars per coin
not quite the highest it looks like it
was a close 63 or something
still i mean april of 20th yeah 63 and
april 15th
so
yeah essentially it's where it was
it's at about its highest point again
people need to understand this is a sign
not of this is not good news okay if you
are if you're a cryptocurrency holder
what this really means is your dollars
are becoming worthless yeah yeah so when
we when we were in uh back in november
when we were talking we had bill ottman
on the show and he was like yo by
ethereum and i was like okay and so i
bought some more bitcoin and ethereum
and then within a few months it was at
30k and i was like whoa
lumber went up at the like basically the
same rate so what i think is actually
happening is when bitcoin skyrockets
like this
what it really means is not that it's
getting more valuable the dollar is
getting less value yeah now they're
saying i saw one report the dollar will
lose half its value in the next like
decade or so next 13 years
and all those set on that money set on
that money it has to i mean because how
much did they print over the last two
years like six trillion i think yeah i
mean like six trillion even though
arguably it's still bs uh the dollar's
not based on anything and it's just a
big joke at this point but when you
print that much over the last year it
has to fall and and they've been kicking
the can down the road for i mean longer
than i've ever seen in my lifetime i've
seen it economies come and go nothing's
been like this
uh but yeah anytime he's like even
before the internet anytime you start
seeing some old guy trying to sell you
gold you know the oh we're about to go
into a recession
uh and like the same thing is happening
here except the new gold is bitcoin but
and it might be a i would recommend it
uh or
financial advice no financial advice i
don't know anything i used to own a
comic store but i keep a lot of cash in
my safe
um
that's what that's what i do because
i'm not really sure i mean
i i don't know how bad it's gonna get
it's this is the worst i've ever seen it
and with the
since the shoe hasn't dropped yet
uh and it's gonna be it's only a matter
of time really uh i i don't know i think
it's gonna get worse people realize that
they have not demand is about to spike
for thanksgiving and christmas oh yeah
and with already constru like
constrained supply lines that could snap
it yeah totally travel already super
expensive and you know we talk about how
the vax mandates are really bad but a
lot of people aren't talking about how
the biden administration literally wants
to pass a 3.5 trillion dollar bill which
one of the provisions is a surveillance
bill where the biden administration will
be literally looking at everyone's bank
account to make sure that everyone's
paying the irs if they have over six
hundred dollars in their bank accounts i
mean this is a massive surveillance bill
this is a massive increasing into
people's personal liberties people's
personal freedoms and they're gonna be
paying for this bill by taxing everyone
over 600 when they print the money out
of thin air text the poor it's insane
it's it just seems cruel it's more cruel
than logical in my opinion i completely
agree and nobody's talking about it like
nobody's upset about it you should be
very very upset about this this is this
is the bank the the democrats in their
bill and their spending bill want access
to the income and outgoing money from
your bank account if you have at least
600 bucks yeah and nancy pelosi and
janet yellen are literally arguing
saying this is going to get the
billionaires guys this is going to go
after the billionaires because
billionaires have accounts with 600
bucks yeah yeah this is going to go
after what they've been after the whole
time the middle class they've always
been after the middle class when you're
attacking the rich it's tax the middle
class you can tax all the rich people
you want well it's not going to make a
difference a lot of the multi uh you
know billionaire corporations a lot of
these super wealthy people call for more
taxes call for more regulations because
it will destroy their competitors as of
course they save their money in a lot of
different safe havens so
they're fine as you are literally paying
every single dime every single penny
which the irs knows exactly how much you
owe you make a mistake they'll send you
a bill right away saying no no no no we
know exactly exactly how much you owe
you you unders understated your taxes
you know why not just tell people if
you're going to be doing that anyway but
but you're going to have to pay every
little last cent of this to go into a
hole that literally is going into
nowhere meanwhile the multinational
corporations get to do whatever they
want
play by a different set of rules as
you're getting screwed every single day
and your dollar that you worked hard for
is being devalued right in front of your
eyes inflation is a tax on your savings
and holy cow are they taxing the crap
out of you but bitcoin
is a hedge against that
i'm not giving anybody advice but i'll
tell you this i'm particularly happy
with my purchase of bitcoin over the
past several years i i remember when it
was at uh
like 1300 or whatever several years ago
and i was thinking to myself like
like dude i just wish i would have
bought when it was a couple hundred
bucks
and then i i was like i'll just buy some
now i'll just put some of my savings
into it and boy was that a good idea
anyway luke and i were talking about the
other day
when you know i was like bitcoin's gonna
hit a million bucks and then luke was
like and then we're gonna be thinking
back to when i was at 60 and being like
why didn't we buy when it was at 60.
and that was a joke i made like it if
you look at the trends some people are
projecting 200k in the next month or two
yep i think so i do i do i don't know
but if you look at the trends similar
trends happening it should spike and max
keiser also called it and he's been he's
been within margin of like his
predictions quite a bit i'll just put it
this way man i'm going to advise anybody
other than the us dollars becoming
worthless uh yeah you're twenty dollars
if they raise the minimum wage to like
twenty dollars an hour it'll be worth
ten so yeah yeah that's that's just what
you said that
the dollar is worthless it's the you
know the big mac index i think they call
it you ever hear that yes they they
gauge the strength of economy by by a
working-class person's ability to buy a
big mac something like that and so it's
like how many hours do you have to work
to purchase a big mac
and so they'll look at a bunch of
countries and a lot for a lot of
countries like you got to work four or
five hours to get one big mac that's a
bad economy in the united states it's
like you can work for one hour and
actually get to big mac yeah so it's a
good economy
right now
if a big mac costs five bucks
and you're getting 10 bucks an hour
you're getting two big macs an hour
but if they increase the minimum minimum
wage
what's really going to happen is that
big mac's going to go up in cost and
you're still going to be getting two big
macs per hour the amount of money you
make is not relevant to the cost of the
materials and the labor to produce the
product the left doesn't get it
there is one benefit when it comes to
imports because raising the wages in the
united states won't change imported
goods from other countries which maybe
they're trying to do hoping that okay
the economy is collapsing but what if
like your computer
was
cheaper because everyone or not cheaper
but you're making more money now you can
afford to get it the computers are still
going to get expensive but they're
hoping they can like outpace the the
imported goods as they outsource more
and more of our manufacturing and
products overseas so this just sounds to
me like we're giving more of our power
to countries overseas so that's not good
first of all second of all i'm very glad
that you guys as bitcoin investment are
going up but at the same time that
terrifies me because it lets me know
that everything that i'm earning and
everything i'm doing trying to pay off
my own debts it's for nothing the value
of my dollar is falling no that's good
your debt's becoming worthless too yeah
that's great so it's like i was exciting
so this is what the u.s does though the
u.s purposefully inflates so that the
debt they owe is worth less
so if 20 bucks can buy you two
cheeseburgers
and you
say let's say i borrow 20 bucks from you
to buy two cheeseburgers i owe you the
equivalent of two meals i wait until
inflation hits and the 20 bucks can only
buy one cheeseburger and then i only got
to pay you back one when you gave me two
you see how that works
that's the trick china is also
implementing a very similar policy
they've been acting like they have blank
checkbooks and they've been writing
checks all over africa all over latin
america and buying a lot of influence
buying a lot of resources buying a lot
of manufacturing buying a lot of
relationships that slowly and surely are
overtaking the united states and their
sphere of influence in those particular
regions so it's very interesting to see
china implement the same role but
instead of just giving it to
multinational corporations they're using
it to build their country to make sure
that they have enough natural resources
for their people as they're of course
more of a nationalistic government
meanwhile our government keeps selling
us out every single day yep
and it gets rooted on uh by more than
half the country every day and that's
the thing we have to fight is that
influence in that that apathy or either
rooting for one team or that apathy
uh and we see it it's all throughout our
culture uh and yeah i worry about the
future uh i've got kids
uh i'm gonna buy a you know buying a
house soon i don't like i have no idea
what we're getting into that's why i
just i think it's a good time to not
give up but like uh fortify your future
fortify your future if you can uh by
getting out of a city uh but not
everybody can
uh and the the one thing
i learned
through through covid was i i never paid
attention to like local elections
san francisco's a waste of time but
um that's something i'm going to pay
attention to
every day now every time everywhere i
move i'm going to know who the dog
catcher is i'm going to know who
everybody who lords over me is i want to
know everything about them
and that's on that's where i can make
the change thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you